the next story today we are going to be
talking about is Adam 22.
Adam Adam Adam
so this week his sex tape
are not his sex tape so this week Adam
22's wife Lena's sex tape with this porn
stars video dropped so they have been
marketing it all week all week promoting
it Adam's just saying wow I am so proud
of my wife for getting her back blown
out now I know I was uncomfortable with
this before but now I'm just super
turned on and so into my wife getting
railed by other dudes and I'm very proud
so
now
Adam
has liked a tweet so he said there was a
tweet that said God damn he he
the out of Adam 22's wife had her
biting the bed sheets and screaming
Adam 22 liked this tweet
he liked this tweet talking about how
another guy
slept with his wife so what do the men
say about this Adam is the type of guy
who says oh sorry when he walks in on
his wife with another guy and this is
the thing Adam
no guy can respect you ever after this
I'm sorry why
why why this is degeneracy and the funny
thing is they'll say oh you know
um
the kids will be fine and we'll just
wait until later till they're older to
tell them and but my thing is why are
you guys playing with your kids Mental
Health
you know it's very possible that the
kids will be fine after all this but is
it really fair to the kid to make
decisions that are going to affect the
kid
then I what response was that to my
tweet so I I oh I had a tweet from my
last show I I pulled a clip talking
about Adam
talking about Adam and he offers me I'll
give you a million dollars to come on
plug talk and experience your first
threesome you have got to live a little
Pearl
and this is what the left does they try
to bring us into their degeneracy
they try to bring us into this nonsense
this craziness
um
you know
I am good I'm okay no thank you NADA no
no no unlike some of the women that are
on your show I had a dad in my life okay
no offense to those women but you know I
did have a dad and
I did have a dad and that's a no no
thank you from me trying to think of
what else we could talk about
the
am I getting uncomfortable even like
rejecting this offer I'm like ew get
away from me
um okay I wanna I wanna say one more
thing about Adam 22. and this is the
thing okay you cannot live a life
outside of this craziness without the
left trying to drag you into it without
all of these degenerate crazy people
trying to and this is what they'll do
they'll attack you personally they'll
dig into your past they'll they'll dig
for any piece of dirt they can find on
you and what they'll do is they'll try
to bring you into this degeneracy and
the crazy thing is I I just want to know
how much they're making off of this
because I I want to know what amount of
money was worth it to you what amount of
money was worth this like degeneracy and
I bet you this becomes a pattern like
how many men is he gonna give his wife
to in the next year
it's not gonna end it's not gonna end
but you know call me crazy call me
old-fashioned maybe I just don't wanna
maybe I just don't want to live
because I think you know maybe don't do
corn don't I don't know have all this
sexual stuff on camera for the world to
see maybe don't let other men sleep with
your wife I don't know maybe I'm just
old-fashioned call me crazy